hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live ein Thema über das viele von uns
sich Gedanken machen und sich auch noch
weiter Gedanken machen werden sind die
gestiegenen Energiepreise und vor allem
wie wird das Ganze jetzt Richtung Herbst
und Winter der heiße Sommer ist vorbei
aber natürlich die Probleme die sind
nicht weg sondern im Gegenteil die
werden immer größer und das ist heute
unser Thema denn viele haben Sorge sich
das nicht mehr leisten zu können im
Winter mit gestiegenen Energiekosten und
die Bundesregierung hat dazu eventuell
heute Antworten für uns denn sie hat
eingeladen das Bundeskanzleramt zu einer
Pressekonferenz gleich um 14 Uhr soll es
losgehen und zwar zum Thema aktuelle
Fragen zur Energieversorgung in
Deutschland wir sind live für euch und
haben danach auch noch Zeit viel Zeit
nehmen wir uns um gemeinsam eure Fragen
zu beantworten bei der Pressekonferenz
erwarten wir den Bundeskanzler ob
virtuell oder in Personen das wird sich
dann noch zeigen außerdem
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck und
Finanzminister Christian Lindner denn
wir alle haben fragen wie soll es denn
weitergehen und wir haben jetzt kurz
einen kleinen Beitrag für euch noch
vorbereitet denn die vier führenden
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute haben ihr
Herbstgutachten für die Bundesregierung
vorgelegt und das sieht düster aus ein
Wort das ist besonders unterstrichen
Wohlstandsverlust und zwar für uns alle
ein Bericht von Nicole Diekmann
Energiekrise Inflation Rezession
Wohlstandsverlust die überschriftdüster
die Aussichten entsprechend der Krieg in
der Ukraine trifft auch Deutschland mit
voller Wucht und zwar nachhaltig dies
eine der Kernbotschaften der anhaltende
Einkommensverlust den wir erwarten die
Gaspreise werden nicht auf das
ursprüngliche Niveau zurückkehren dass
wir vor der Krise gesehen haben
bedeutet ein Wohlstandsverlust für die
Deutschen für die deutsche Bevölkerung
den die Wirtschaftspolitik nicht
ausgleichen kann 2024 erst werde die
Inflation wieder sinken im laufenden
Jahr liegt sie bei 8,4 Prozent 2023
dabei 8,8 so die Schätzung der Staat
könne und solle eingreifen aber nicht
mit der Gießkanne so die einhellige
Meinung bei der Finanzpolitik das hier
gezielte Maßnahmen zum Einsatz kommen
nämlich genau dort an der Stelle wo eben
der Konjunktureinbruch wenn Sie so
wollen verursacht wird nämlich bei den
aushalten die eben keine Kaufkraft mehr
haben um sich ihren täglichen
Lebensunterhalt leisten zu können die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit deutscher
Unternehmen werde in einigen Teilen
leiden und wir brechen den Beitrag jetzt
an dieser Stelle ab zeigen ihn euch
später wieder denn jetzt beginnt die
Pressekonferenz und wir schalten live
drauf der Bundeskanzler spricht
brutaler unverändert fort
aber Russland setzt nicht nur im Krieg
Waffen ein sondern setzt auch
international seine Energielieferung als
war Verein
deshalb können wir spätestens nach den
Zerstörungen an den Pipelines den
Gaspipelines in der Ostsee sagen auf
absehbare Zeit wird Gas aus Russland
nicht mehr geliefert werden
wir sind allerdings auf diese Situation
vorbereitet wir haben Entscheidungen
getroffen die es uns ermöglichen mit
dieser veränderten Situation umzugehen
Deutschland importiert Gas von anderen
Ländern wir hatten die Kapazitäten der
westeuropäischen Häfen der Niederlande
Belgiens und Frankreichs wir waren
flüssiggast Terminals an den
norddeutschen Küsten unsere Speicher
sind zu über 90% gefüllt die
Kohlekraftwerke werden wieder in Betrieb
genommen und viele sind es bereits wir
nutzen die Kapazitäten der
deutschen Atomkraftwerke in den Monaten
Januar Februar März April wenn das
notwendig ist und wir werden alles dafür
tun dass wir auch unsere Speicher nutzen
dann für den Winter so dass die Lage
entspannt werden kann und wir eine gute
Versorgung haben
aber klar das führt trotzdem dazu dass
die Preise hoch sind und damit sind
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber viele
Unternehmen unseren blonde für eine
große Herausforderung gestellt die sich
nicht einfach bewältigen lässt die
Preise müssen runter das ist unser ganz
entscheidender Überzeugung dafür wird
die Bundesregierung alles tun damit die
Preise sinken spannen wir jetzt einen
großen Abwehrschirm ein Abwehrschirm der
dazu beitragen soll dass die Rentner und
Rentner in unserem Land das die
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitnehmer die
Familien auf dem Lande und in der Stadt
dass die Singles dass die Verkäuferinnen
und Verkäufer das alle gut zurechtkommen
können und dass sie die Preise bezahlen
können aber auch der Bäckermeister um
die Ecke die Handwerkerin oder die
großen Industriebetriebe die auf Strom
und gastlieferungen angewiesen sind die
jetzt viel zu teuer sind
dieser Abwehrschirm wird gespeist aus
dem neu dazu benutzen Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds 200 Milliarden Euro
ausstatten werden diese 200 Milliarden
Euro werden wir durch eine
Kreditaufnahme finanzieren und damit in
der Lage sein in diesem Jahr im nächsten
Jahr und dem übernächsten Jahr die
Aufgaben zu bewältigen jetzt vor uns
stehen
eine Maßnahme zur Senkung der Preise
haben wir bereits auf den Weg gebracht
und es wird jetzt einfacher das ist die
strompreisbremse sie wird gerade
vorbereitet jetzt geht es um eine
gaspreisbremse dazu haben wir eine
Kommission eingesetzt die ganz konkrete
Vorschläge in kürzester Zeit machen wird
aber was jetzt möglich ist ist dass sie
die Mittel einsetzen kann damit die
Preise sinken für die Verbraucher und
Verbraucher überall im Land für die
Familien für die Rentner und Rentner für
die Handwerk und Handwerker aber eben
auch für die Unternehmen die kleinen und
großen und das ist doch dringend
notwendig damit wir durch diese
schwierige Zeit kommen mit den 200
Milliarden Euro haben wir die
Möglichkeiten das alles zu finanzieren
und dazu beizutragen dass das
funktioniert
klar das versetzt uns auch in die Lage
auf die unter anderem Umständen auch als
es noch Gaslieferung aus Russland gab
geplante gasumlage zu verzichten sie
wird nicht mehr gebraucht wir werden die
Unternehmen und da geht es vor allem
drei direkt unterstützen so dass das
nicht zu einer Mehrbelastung der
Verbrauchern Verbrauchern viele andere
Unternehmen führt aber diese Unternehmen
trotzdem wirtschaftlich durch diese
Situation kommen können und ihre Aufgabe
für die Gasversorgung Deutschlands auch
weiter wahrnehmen können
das alles zusammen sind weitreichende
Entlastungsmaßnahmen die dann noch
ergänzt werden durch ganz konkrete
Hilfen für Unternehmen die nicht bereits
durch die Entlastung bei den Preisen
besser durch die Lage kommen als das
heute der Fall ist für uns ist ganz klar
das ist eine Aufgabe die das ganze Land
gemeinsam schultern muss wir müssen uns
unterhaken und wir können uns auch
unterhaken wir haben eine
leistungsfähige Volkswirtschaft wir
haben stabile Staatsfinanzen auch durch
die sehr sorgfältige Politik der letzten
Jahre und die die wir in den nächsten
Jahren planen indem wir dafür sorgen
dass wir immer so gut wie möglich mit
den Vorgaben unsere Verfassung umgehend
dafür sorgen dass wir gute aufgestellte
Haushalte haben aber jetzt schaffen wir
die Kraft mit dem Abwehrschirm das zu
tun damit Strompreise damit Gaspreise
sinken dramatisch sinken und damit sie
von den Bürgern und Bürgern und den
Unternehmen bewältigt werden können das
ist die Aufgabe wir jetzt haben und
diese Aufgabe Schultern wir auch ich
habe aber andere Gelegenheit gesagt die
Maßnahmen die wir ergreifen sind ein
Bums man kann sagen dass es hier ein
doppelbums es soll dazu beitragen dass
jetzt schnell zügig und für alle schnell
feststellbar die Preise sinken für
Energie so dass sich niemand Sorgen
machen muss wenn er an den Herbst und
den Winter denkt wenn er an Weihnachten
denkt und dann das nächste Jahr und dann
die Rechnung auch die hohen Rechnungen
die einige jetzt bereits bekommen haben
als Abschlagszahlung werden sich dann
wieder reduzieren können das ist das
konkrete ziel der Maßnahme und der
Förderung die wir uns vorgenommen haben
meine Damen und Herren der russische
Krieg gegen die Ukraine geht unverändert
weiter und er nimmt dann Brutalität und
härtet zu wir sehen das jeden Tag
trotzdem sind wir überzeugt dass die
Ukrainer und Ukraine in der Lage sein
werden die Integrität und Souveränität
ihres Landes zu verteidigen auch weil
sie sich darauf verlassen können dass
die Weltgemeinschaft nicht einfach
zuschauen wenn ein großer mächtiger
Nachbar
ein anderes Land überfällt und wir
werden unsere Solidarität fortsetzen
aber wir sind auch in der Lage dafür zu
sorgen dass unser Land das
wirtschaftlich stark ist eine so große
Herausforderung bewältigen kann dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihr Leben führen
können dass die Preise für Energie nicht
durch die Decke schießen sondern dass
sie für Sie alle bewältigbar sind und
für die Unternehmen die für unsere
Arbeitsplätze wichtig sind auch schönen
Dank
vielen Dank als nächstes Robert Habeck
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die Energiekrise die wir in
Europa erleben droht sich zu einer
Wirtschafts- und auch einer sozialen
Krise auszuwachsen mit der Entscheidung
die wir heute vorstellen
unterbinden wir das halten wir gegen wie
der Bundeskanzler gesagt hat das ist
eine große Entscheidung 200 Milliarden
für einen Abwehrschirm der dann
verausgabt über den Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds tatsächlich
abwehren soll tatsächlich den Angriff
von Russland von Putins Regime auf
unsere Volkswirtschaft und über eine
Destabilisierung unserer Volkswirtschaft
eine Destabilisierung der demokratischen
Ordnung in Europa und in Deutschland zu
erreichen das ist die Macht die wir
Putin gegeben haben durch eine zu große
Abhängigkeit von Gas und das ist die
Gegenwehr heute mit dem Abwehrschirm die
wir ergreifen und diese Macht zu brechen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ist ein
großer und ein bedeutender Schritt es
ist aber auch einer der in seiner
Pauschalität und in seiner massiven
Wirkung für die Alternativen die wir
sonst gearbeitet haben eine deutliche
Verbesserung darstellt er ist pauschaler
er ist einfacher und er ist schneller
das ist nur möglich weil er ein so
großes Volumen stellt und ich möchte
mich beim Finanzminister bei Christian
Lindner bedanken dass dieses große
Volumen erbracht werden konnte
dieser Schritt ist eben auch eine
Maßnahme die Unterstützung für die
Bevölkerung und für die Unternehmen
bürokratiearm zu gestalten weil wir den
Preis insgesamt jetzt im Gasbereich und
parallel dazu im Strombereich senken und
decken
wir bringen und das sage ich als
Wirtschaftsminister wir bringen eine
enorme finanzielle Kraft auf um die
Zukunftsfähigkeit und die
Investitionsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft zu schützen und zu erhalten
das ist wichtig und notwendig es geht
nicht nur darum irgendwie durch diese
Krise durchzukommen sondern als starke
robuste Volkswirtschaft diese Zeit zu
bestehen um dann in der Zukunft die
weiteren Aufgaben die uns
gesellschaftlich gestellt sind zu
bestehen
mit der Abschaffung der gasumlage wird
ebenfalls Bürokratie reduziert die
gasumlage war ein Instrument um die
Versorgungssicherheit in Deutschland zu
gewähren sie hat ja den Verlust von
Energie bei gleichlaufenden Verträgen
der großen Unternehmen kompensieren
sollen
sie war ein wichtiges Instrument für die
Versorgungssicherheit jetzt gibt es
andere Instrumente das finanzielle
Volumen das jetzt geschaffen wurde stand
vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten doch
nicht zur Verfügung insofern ist es
folgerichtig und richtig dass wir dieses
Instrument auch nutzen um die
Unternehmen anders zu kapitalisieren und
die Versorgungssicherheit und die
Möglichkeit der Unternehmen weiter Gas
einzukaufen jetzt anders zu gewähren und
bereitzustellen
wenn ich bei Versorgungssicherheit bin
möchte ich nicht schließen ohne darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir nach wie vor in
einer kritischen Situation sind und die
Verbräuche runtergehen müssen bei der
bei dem Design der Gasanlage die ja
maßgeblich von der Kommission die
eingesetzt wurde von der Bundesregierung
vorgenommen werden soll muss darauf
geachtet werden dass die
spitzenverbräuche nicht subventioniert
werden dass die spitzenverbräuche
runtergehen wir sind immer noch in einer
kritischen Situation ja es ist zu wie
der Bundeskanzler gesagt hat die
Speicher sind voll aber wir sehen auch
dass die verbreche gerade im privaten
Bereich noch nicht in dem Maße
runtergehen wie es eigentlich notwendig
wäre deswegen bei aller Bereitschaft
jetzt viel Geld in die Hand zu nehmen
und die Preise abzufedern die
Notwendigkeit Energie einzusparen bleibt
unvermindert bestehen vielen Dank
vielen Dank und als drittes im Bunde
ja meine Damen und Herren man kann es
nicht anders sagen wir befinden uns in
einem energiekrieg um Wohlstand und
Freiheit nach der Sabotage von noch
unbekannter Hand in der Ostsee hat sich
die Lage weiter verschärft wir können
jetzt nicht mehr davon ausgehen Gas aus
Russland zu beziehen dieser energiekrieg
hat zum Ziel
vieles von dem zu zerstören was die
Menschen sich persönlich über Jahrzehnte
aufgebaut haben was über Jahrzehnte an
Strukturen in Mittelstand Handwerk und
Industrie aufgebaut worden ist wir
können das nicht akzeptieren und werden
uns zur Wehr setzen
was wir heute vorstellen dass wir
erarbeitet haben dieser Beschluss das
ist eine glasklare Antwort an Putin aber
ist auch eine glasklare
Richtungsweisung an die Menschen in
unserem Land wir sind wirtschaftlich
stark und diese wirtschaftliche Stärke
mobilisieren wir wenn es erforderlich
ist so wie jetzt
wir haben einen Abwehrschirm gegen
diesen energiekrieg in wirtschaftlicher
Hinsicht beschlossen um die Folgen der
Knappheiten für die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher und die Wirtschaft
abzufedern und um Zeit zu gewinnen und
vorzubereiten auf eine neue Normalität
nach dieser Krise wir haben beraten auf
welchem Wege das gelingen kann ich habe
dazu den Bundeskanzler und den
Wirtschaftsminister die Reaktivierung
des Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds vorgeschlagen wir
werden Ihnen mit bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro in diesem Jahr befüllen oder anders
gesagt damit stehen bis zu 200
Milliarden Euro an Kriseninterventionen
zur Verfügung für die Zeit der Krise in
der voraussehbaren Zukunft 22 23 24 zum
Vergleich während der corona-pandemie
war der Wirtschaft stabilisierungsfond
mit 600 Milliarden gefüllt worden und im
Jahr
2008 haben wir im Zuge der
bankenrettungspakete etwa 500 Milliarden
Euro gesehen also dieser Abwehrschirm
ist umfassend und wirksam er ist
zugleich aber gezielt auf diese Krise er
ist ein Schutz vor Existenzverlust aber
er soll selbst nicht die Inflation
befeuern und ausdrücklich folgen wir
nicht dem Beispiel Großbritanniens auf
den Weg einer expansiven
Fiskalpolitik aus diesem Grund wählen
wir ja das Instrument Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds mit einer klaren
gesetzlichen Zielbestimmung auf
Krisenbewältigung und aus diesem Grund
gilt für den Bundeshaushalt 2023 also
für die allgemeinen politischen Vorhaben
weiterhin die regelbremse der Schuld die
Regelgrenze der Schuldenbremse dazu
gleich noch Einsatz hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm warten Aufgaben vor uns wir
stellen den auf um mit finanziellen
Mitteln Zeit zu gewinnen um erstens
unsere Energieversorgung neu zu
programmieren also die Erneuerbaren wie
ich sie in eine freiheitsenergien an den
Start zu bringen auch durch
beschleunigte Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren wir geben jetzt
grünes Licht für Offshore Windenergie
wir nutzen für die Zeit der Krise hinter
diesem Abwehrschirm die Kohle bis 2024
wir haben auch jetzt beschrieben in dem
Papier was der Status Quo bei der
Kernenergie ist also zwei Süddeutsche
Kraftwerke auch im Frühjahr 2023 zu
verwenden das ist noch Gegenstand auch
der weiteren Beratung und
Meinungsbildung ist das worauf wir jetzt
schon bauen können sagt ganz offen ich
bin der Überzeugung wir brauchen alle
Kernkraftwerke auch bis 2024 das hat sie
auch nicht verändert wir werden
ausspeichern aus dem mit ihrem Geld
befüllten Gas speichern nicht alles aber
so viel um Marktsignale zu senden und
wir setzen auf europäische Lösungen also
das erste was wir tun hinter dem
Abwehrschirm ist unsere Energie und
Gasversorgung so aufstellen dass wir
über die Zeit und in ein neues normal
kommen das zweite wir erneuern und
stärker unsere Wirtschaft insgesamt wir
haben rekordinvestitionen im
Bundeshaushalt dabei bleibt es damit
erneuern wir von der digitalen bis zur
Schieneninfrastruktur unser Land und
investieren gezielt auch über den
klima-verbesserungen in dauerhafte
Stärkung der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit meine
Damen und Herren um diese Erneuerung und
Stärkung unserer Wirtschaft nicht zu
beeinträchtigen haben wir ein
belastungsmoratorium beschlossen während
der Zeit der Krise und während wir
diesen Abwehrschirm haben wird diese
Bundesregierung keine Maßnahmen
unterstützen oder auf den Weg bringen
die mit einem unverhält regelmäßigen
zusätzlichen Bürokratieaufwand für
Mittelstand Handwerk oder Industrie
verbunden sind in dieser Zeit der Krise
hinter dem Abwehrschirm muss sich die
Wirtschaft darauf konzentrieren können
sich vorzubereiten sich wieder zu
stärken Substanz zu erhalten wir wollen
sie nicht mit lästiger mit ärgerlicher
Bürokratie in dieser Zeit behelligen und
drittens abschließend hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm werden wir an den
Eckpunkten unserer Haushaltsplanung
Festhalten der Bundeshaushalt 2023 also
unter den Bedingungen der Schuldenbremse
ist völlig klar dass das nur geht wegen
des abwehrschirms aber auch viele
Unternehmen werden nur wegen des
abwehrschirms weiter im Markt
erfolgreich sein das gleiche gilt für
den Bundeshaushalt auch zu ohne den
Abwehrschirm wäre 2023 aus dem regulären
Haushalt natürlich eine gaspreisbremse
etwa nicht zu finanzieren aber wir
wollen eben klar Krisen Ausgaben trennen
von unserer regulären Haushaltsführung
sonst wäre es möglicherweise nicht
möglich auch darüber hinausgehende
Wünsche
zurückzuweisen durch diese Maßnahme
wollen wir ein ganz klares Signal an die
Kapitalmärkte senden auch wenn wir jetzt
einen solchen Abwehrschirm nutzen hält
Deutschland an seiner
stabilitätsorientierten an
Nachhaltigkeit interessierten
Finanzpolitik fest die deutschen
Staatsanleihen bleiben der Goldstandard
in der Welt darauf kann sich jeder
verlassen und auch die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger dürfen wissen dass wir weiter
sorgsam mit dem Geld der
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
umgehen jede zusätzliche Ausgabe auf
Kredit die wir jetzt leisten muss
zurückgezahlt muss mit zins- und Tilgung
bedient werden und würde dann die
Freiheit der künftigen
Generationen einschränken solide
Finanzpolitik ist also auch eine Form
der freiheitspolitik wenn uns das
dieses Paket jetzt rasch auf den Weg zu
bringen und den Ehrgeiz haben wir dann
wird dieser Abwehrschirm auch als eine
Art inflationsbremse wirken denn wir
dämpfen die Preisentwicklung wir
erhalten das Angebot und bauen Angebot
aus und zugleich gehen wir nicht in die
Richtung einer expansiven Finanzpolitik
noch mal der Vergleich zu Großbritannien
unser Ziel ist also ein Abwehrschirm
aufzubauen der zugleich neben dem
strukturerhalt auch einen wichtigen
Beitrag als inflationsbremse leistet
eine wirtschaftliche weitere
Verschlechterung der Lage abzuwenden
soweit vielen Dank die erste Frage hat
Andreas Rinke und ich habe weitere 6
Fragesteller schon notiert Herr
Bundeskanzler ich hätte ganz gerne
gefragt ob denn in diesem Volumen die
ganzen Ausgabe Wünsche der Länder die ja
gestern beschlossen wurden alle schon
mit einberechnet sind oder droht ihnen
das am vierten Oktober wenn Sie mit den
Ländern verhandeln dann noch viele viele
Milliarden oben drauf kommen und der
Lindner eine ganz kurze Nachfrage
belastungsmoratorium was genau heißt es
heißt es dass da Projekte die im
Koalitionsvertrag
genannt werden mit Belastung für die
Wirtschaft jetzt erstmal zurückgestellt
werden
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich habe die
Beratung der Länder mit großer Interesse
verfolgt und freue mich schon auf die
Fortsetzung des Gesprächs dass wir jetzt
für nächste Woche vereinbart haben meine
Genesung macht auch solche Fortschritte
dass ich hoffen kann dass das
tatsächlich so stattfindet wie ich es
mir wünsche nämlich dass wir uns
persönlich begegnen jedenfalls hatte ich
heute schon den ersten negativen Test
und wenn das anhält dann kann ich ja
darauf hoffen dass die Quarantäne nicht
mehr lange anhält was die
sachgebende betrifft will ich aber gerne
sagen da sind doch sehr kluge
konstruktive Töne und Aussagen bei den
Ländern zu hören gewesen alle wissen
dass wir hier gemeinsam was machen
wollen und dass die Länder auch einen
großen Teil der Aufgaben schultern
müssen dazu habe ich die Bereitschaft
eigentlich von allen auch wahrgenommen
und natürlich ist es ein großes Datum
wenn jetzt der Bund mit 200 Milliarden
Euro der aus eigenen Krediten die er
selber Kredit finanziert dazu beiträgt
dass alle Lasten geringer werden die
Kosten für die Krankenhäuser die dort
neu bedrohtlich entstanden sind werden
geringer wenn die Energiekosten wieder
sinken das gilt für die sozialen
Einrichtungen für die Schulen für die
Universitäten das gilt
selbstverständlich auch für all das was
am Förderprogramm möglicherweise sonst
den Ländern notwendig wäre wenn der Hund
auf diese Art und Weise dafür sorgt dass
die Energiekosten sinken und die Sinken
der Inflation hilft dann ja auch ganz
konkret bei der Bewältigung der Aufgaben
den Ländern stehen insofern glaube ich
machen diese 200 Milliarden Euro doch
schon eine ganz erhebliche Veränderung
aus in Richtung einer gemeinsamen Tagung
der Lasten und der Anteil des Bundes ist
dann eben über die 50 Prozent die wir
knapp an dem bisherigen Paket zu
finanzieren haben hinaus noch dann die
ganze Summe von 200 Milliarden also ein
Vielfaches der Aufgaben die Länder und
Gemeinden stemmen insofern bin ich
sicher wir kommen zueinander
ja Herr Rinke also zunächst mal ist
einer der positivsten weiteren positiven
Nachrichten des heutigen Tages der
negative Test des Bundeskanzlers ich
glaube das ist jetzt ein guter Anlass
noch mal für das Präparat paxlovit zu
werben das habe ich nämlich während
meiner hotel-quarantäne in Washington
auch bekommen und war bin fünf Tagen bei
mild und Verlauf
negativ also ich glaube das sollte in
Deutschland öfter genutzt werden wir
haben es ja auch dann hat der
Bundeskanzler völlig zu Recht gesagt
dass wir ja durch jetzt unseren Weg
Strom gaspreisbremse
stützmaßnahmen für Unternehmen
Ablösungen gasumlage und Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm im Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds ja auch die Länder
selbst Sportvereine und so weiter und so
fort entlasten und aus diesem Grund ja
auch vielleicht ein Entgegenkommen der
Länder jetzt willkommen wäre aus den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds selbst
wird es nicht möglich sein Forderungen
der Länder zu bedienen weil der an klar
umrissenen gesetzlichen Zweck bekommt
sie unsere Papier das ist ja gerade die
Idee Stichwort kein Dammbruch das nur
für eine umrissenen
krisenbegrenzten Zweck finanziert werden
kann und bei der Frage
belastungsmoratorium will ich sie nur
auf den Text verweisen der heißt die
Krise führt bei vielen Unternehmen zu
zusätzlichen Belastungen es wird deshalb
sorgfältig darauf geachtet dass während
der Zeit der Krise keine
unverhältnismäßigen zusätzlichen
Bürokratielasten die Wirtschaft
beeinträchtigen in Klammern
belastungsmoratorium
als nächsten Fragenden den Kollegen der
neben andreaswinkel sitzt
ja vielen Dank Daniel bukkaka ARD Herr
Bundeskanzler vor dem Hintergrund dass
die Bundesnetzagentur jetzt gesagt hat
zuletzt wurde im Vergleich zum
vergangenen Jahr 20 Prozent mehr Gas
verbraucht möchte ich Sie fragen ist das
was sie jetzt vorlegen gaspreisbremse
zwar vielleicht zwar populär aber
vielleicht doch das falsche Signal an
die Leute und kommt von ihnen vielleicht
parallel auch noch sowas wie ein
verstärkter Appell oder sogar Regelungen
zum Energieeinsparen
den Appell hat ja der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister bereits
formuliert eben wenige Minuten bevor Sie
Ihre Frage gestellt haben und das ist
unsere Haltung wir wissen dass wir alle
zusammen jetzt schon gucken müssen wie
wir möglichst viel Energie sparen wir
haben allerdings natürlich auch
gleichzeitig dafür gesorgt dass wir es
auch können ich habe bereits geschildert
was wir alles machen dazu zählt ja dass
wir
Kohlekraftwerke wieder in Betrieb nehmen
um statt mit Gas und Kohle Strom zu
produzieren dass wir sie auch nicht aus
dem Betrieb nehmen um den gleichen
Effekt zu erreichen dass wir die
Möglichkeit geschaffen haben das in
Süddeutschland die beiden Atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen können das sind ja schon
auch erhebliche Sparmaßnahmen wir hatten
ohnehin eine große maßenden Menge an
Gesetzen auf den Weg gebracht dieses
Unternehmen ermöglichen dass sie
sparen was Gas betrifft indem sie auf
andere Energieträger umsteigen fühlt
sich genannt diese gesetzlichen
Erleichterung sind auf den Weg gebracht
und werden jetzt überall schon genutzt
wie ich sehe dass gibt viele
Entscheidungen die überall getroffen
werden und die auch dazu beitragen
können dass der gastverbrauch der
vorübergehend etwas Kritisches sinken
kann und das gleiche gilt dann natürlich
dafür dass hier mit
un nein noch mit gesteigerten Tempo
alles dafür tun dass wir auf die
erneuerbaren Energien setzen wir haben
sehr sehr viele Gesetze bereits auf den
Weg gebracht die dazu beitragen dass es
jetzt der Ausbau von offshore Windkraft
von Windkraft an Land von Solarenergie
von Biomasse und auch unser Stromnetze
mit größerer Geschwindigkeit vorangehen
kann und das wird auch dazu beitragen
dass wir erheblich Energie einsparen
insofern ist das das was wir machen
zwei kurze Fragen wenn sie gestanden
Martin Greifer Hans bei die erste
richtet sich wahrscheinlich einen
Harbeck in ihrem Eckpunktepapier bleiben
sie noch etwas unkonkret was sie
ausgestattet und der gaspreisbremse
angeht der steht dann die Übernahme des
privaten Verbrauchs in Teilen gibt es
schon eine grobe Vorstellung welche
Größenordnung wieder gehen heute waren
wir kurz von 80% z.B die Rede des
Verbrauchs oder zweite Frage die sich
wahrscheinlich in den Lindner richtet
das ist ja durchaus ein gewagtes Manöver
was sie hier machen was ich ja wieder
ein frontloading machen wie schon beim
klimafond von 60 Milliarden jetzt gibt
es einen anderen Topf aber eine gleiche
Systematik da ist er noch diese
Verfassungsklage der Union anhängig
haben sie noch mal durchgespielt dass
das was ich jetzt hier tun auf jeden
Fall verfassungsfest ist vielen Dank
die gasfestbremse muss zwei Ziele
gleichzeitig erreichen einmal die
Entlastung für Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher und für die Wirtschaft auf
den Gründen die jetzt mehrfach genannt
werden die Kernsubstanz der deutschen
Wirtschaft zu erhalten auch auf der
Nachfrage Seite wenn die
VerbraucherInnen die Verbraucher werden
dadurch ja auch entlastet also die
ökonomische und die soziale Balance in
Deutschland zu wahren und gleichzeitig
so klug programmiert sein oder
aufgestellt sein dass der Anreiz Energie
zu sparen Gas zu sparen erhalten bleibt
der Weg wird sein dass die gaskommission
die wir einen berufen haben dort
Vorschläge oder einen Vorschlag vorlegen
wird die sind auch mit Hochdruck an der
Arbeit und ich finde es ausdrücklich
richtig und klug diesen Weg zu gehen
weil dort ja ein breites Expertengremium
zusammenkommt wo dann
Verbraucherschützerin
Verbraucherschützer aber auch
Unternehmen und
Industrievertreter an einem Tisch sitzen
die dann die verschiedenen
kommunizierenden Röhren jeweils aus
ihrer Sicht beitragen können und
ich die gasquisition hat ja eigentlich
ein bisschen mehr Zeit auch um ganz
andere und sehr komplexe Fragen
beispielsweise der Marktordnung jetzt
für uns große Anteile der deutschen
Gasversorger quasi staatlich
verantwortet sind neu zu denken also was
machen wir eigentlich mit den
Unternehmen das sind ja auch Fragen aber
die sind nicht so dringlich wie die
Frage wie sieht die gaspreisbremse im
konkreten aus deswegen da will ich aber
auch gute Hoffnung dass das gelingt
denke ich dass die Vorschläge dazu
zeitnah als eigentlich erwartet
vorgestellt werden und dann werden wir
die beraten und nach kurzer
beratungsfrist schnell umsetzen
ergreife das
Verfahren ist nicht riskant denn die
bisherige Klage der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist ja schon
unbegründet
das war beim zweiten Nachtrag 2021 ganz
klarer
Veranlassungszusammenhang in der
corona-pandemie nicht erfolgte
Investitionen nachholen zu können über
den Klima und transformationsfonds
vorliegend ist der
Veranlassungszusammenhang ebenfalls
vollkommen eindeutig ein Angriffskrieg
Russlands auf die Ukraine in Verbindung
mit einem energiekrieg Deutschlands
es war jetzt erforderlich politisch
kommunikativ und haushaltspolitisch
klarzumachen dass das nötige Volumen für
diesen Abwehrschirm zur Verfügung steht
in anderen setzen gesagt Deutschland
zeigt hier seine wirtschaftliche
Schlagkraft in einem energiekrieg und
deshalb musste jetzt auch diese Größe
von bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro man wird
ja sehen welches Volumen am Ende
benötigt worden sein wird das auch zu
zeigen und der Veranlassungszusammenhang
ist noch eindeutiger in einer solchen
Situation wie wir sie jetzt haben
erwarte ich auch dass die cdu/csu
Bundestagsfraktion im Prinzip diesem
Vorgehen zustimmt denn Teile der
Maßnahmen die wir jetzt umsetzen sind ja
selbst von dort auch vorgeschlagen
worden freilich ohne jeden
Finanzierungsvorschlag
als nächstes auf der Liste Gerald rauf
wenn er vom Spiegel
wir haben Herr Scholz im bereuen Sie
dass sie nicht schon am 22 juli bei
ihrer Pressekonferenz diesen großen Wurf
gemacht haben und damit dann riskiert
haben dass über den Sommer und jetzt
auch bisschen in den Herbst hinein eine
große Debatte in Brand ist und ja
vielleicht diese Frage erstmal
vielen Dank für Ihre Frage wir haben
zunächst ein Problem gelöst hat
lösen müssen das zu tun hatte damit dass
ein Teil der Lieferung aus Russland
nicht mehr Erfolg ist und deshalb
Unternehmen in großen Schwierigkeiten
gereibten sind die Lieferverträge hatten
die sich nicht mehr bedienen konnten
weil das Gas das sie weiter verkaufen
wollten nicht mehr geliefert wurde und
sie alles neu zu hören Preisen einkaufen
dann aber
weitergeben mussten zu den geringeren
vereinbarten Preisen wir werden also
alle nicht in Lage gewesen diese
Situation zu überleben jetzt sehen wir
dass es gar keine Gaslieferung mehr gibt
das ist ja nun seit einiger Zeit
unübersehbar und Gott sei Dank haben wir
uns genau darauf vorbereitet und deshalb
haben wir auch sehr früh in richtiger
Abfolge die notwendigen Entscheidungen
getroffen zum Beispiel die
gastkommission die uns jetzt Mitte
Oktober wahrscheinlich sehr sehr schnell
wir haben jetzt ja Ende September das
wird nicht viele Tage dauern ein
Vorschlag mal zur Umsetzung der
gaspreisbremse diese Gas diese
gastkommission haben wir schon als
Regierung vor einiger Zeit auf den Weg
gebracht und beschlossen dass sie Tagen
soll und ihre Arbeit machen soll als wir
das dritte große Entlastungspaket von
nochmal 65 Milliarden Euro auf den Weg
gebracht hatten und das war klar für uns
dass bei dieser Gelegenheit natürlich
die Regierung die Kommission auch in die
Lage versetzen muss dass sie weiß wie
viel Geld sie denn einsetzen kann und ob
wir das Geld mobilisieren dass dazu
notwendig ist deshalb haben wir sehr
systematisch darauf hingearbeitet
rechtzeitig zu Beginn der Beratung eine
solche Aussage machen zu können und
genau das tun wir insofern ist das jetzt
hier ein sehr weitreichender ein sehr
dramatischer Schritt der aber genau der
richtige ist in dieser Situation und
wenn ich den Überblick vom Ergebnis darf
unsere drei entlastungspakete haben
zusammen fast 100 Milliarden mit vielen
entlastungsbürgern und Bürger der
Verbesserung des Wohngeldes zum Beispiel
der neue Konstruktion des Bürgergeldes
mit
erhöhten Kindergeld das Bezahlen mit
Steuerentlastung für viele Bürgerinnen
und Bürger der Möglichkeit die
Rentenbeiträge vom steuerpflichtigen
Einkommen abzuziehen also vielen vielen
Entlastung die bei vielen auf
unterschiedliche Weise ankommen und dazu
kommen jetzt noch mal diese 200
Milliarden also das ist eine
lastungsschützen 300 Milliarden der uns
in diesen und den nächsten Jahren helfen
wird durch diese
große schwere Zeit zu kommen aber wir
werden durchkommen weil Deutschland die
wirtschaftliche Kraft hat und den
sozialen Zusammenhalt als soziale
Demokratie der notwendig ist damit man
so eine Herausforderung bewältigen kann
als nächstes
hier Michael bauchmelder sind deutsche
Zeitung eine Frage an Minister Habeck
die gasumlage soll ja am Samstag
eigentlich in Kraft treten was genau
passiert ja jetzt wird die Verordnung
aufgehoben und was geschieht dann mit
jedem gastkunden die schon in Hinblick
auf die Umlage jetzt Preiserhöhungen im
Briefkasten hatten und das wird aus dem
Mehrwertsteuersenkung die auch mit Blick
auf die gasumlage
verabredet wurde dann
kam die Gasanlage ist perverordnung
eingesetzt worden und wird per
Verordnung zurückgezogen werden das
Umlaufverfahren ist eine
Ressortabstimmung im Kabinett ist
eingeleitet also mit Beginn dieser
Pressekonferenz ist diese
ressortbeteiligung eingeleitet werden
eingeleitet worden kurze Frist die
ganzen Lage wird also jetzt vom in die
Annalen der Geschichte eingehen die
sollte es sie gilt ja ab 1.10 sollte es
schon Abzüge geben was
zu überprüfen wäre müssen die
zurückgezahlt werden das dauert dann
vielleicht ein bisschen aber eigentlich
gilt sie am ersten zehnten und deswegen
sind zwar die Briefe gedruckt aber
sehr viel Geld wenn überhaupt kann dann
auch nicht abgezogen worden sein sonst
muss es zurückgezahlt werden die
gasumlage wird nicht mehr benötigt das
haben der Bundeskanzler Christian
Lindner und ich eben ausgeführt weil wir
ein alternatives Finanzinstrument
geschaffen haben wichtig ist
die ganzen Lage da mache ich ja kein
Geheimnis daraus zwar nie ein populäres
Instrument als wir das vorgestellt haben
haben wir immer gesagt das ist eine
schlechte eine
drückende Botschaft die verkündet wird
aber gleichwohl eine notwendige
Botschaft weil ja so wie Olaf Scholz ist
eben gerade dargestellt hat ein Verlust
permanent entsteht im hoher
Milliardenhöhe ohne dass er ausgeglichen
werden kann und dieses Delta musste
geschlossen werden sonst konnten die
Unternehmen ihre wirtschaftliche
Tätigkeit also die Versorgungssicherheit
Einkauf und Weitergabe von Gas nicht
mehr aufrecht erhalten jetzt gibt es
einen besseren Weg einen anderen Weg der
vor ein paar Wochen noch nicht zur
Verfügung stand der ist die
Kapitalisierung der Unternehmen über den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds aus
diesem Volumen von 200 Milliarden Euro
deswegen wird sie nicht mehr benötigt
und wird eben per Verordnung
zurückgezogen werden
oder ist dabei zurückgezogen zu werden
die Mehrwertsteuersenkung allerdings
bleibt und bleibt erhalten und wird auch
aus die auf die fernwärmeverträge
übertragen werden als weiterer Maßnahmen
mit der Entlastung in dieser Zeit wo die
Energiepreise für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger so hoch sind
dann habe ich kein Einstein
ARD einmal gerne noch als Nachfrage
diese Mehrwertsteuersenkung und die
Kosten die damit einhergehen sind die in
diesen 200 Milliarden enthalten oder
kommen die sich schütteln schon den Kopf
die kommen noch on top dann noch eine
Frage an Sie haben Bundeskanzler Scholz
es wurde ja jetzt doch auch auf dem
Podium wieder deutlich dass es bei einem
anderen Energiethema weiterhin ein sehr
sichtbaren Dissens in ihrer
Bundesregierung gibt beim Thema
Atomkraftwerke Herr Lindner hat gerade
noch mal ausgeführt dass seiner Meinung
nach die Atomkraftwerke bis 2024 laufen
müssen
wann wird es da eine Entscheidung
innerhalb der Bundesregierung geben die
Klarheit darüber
schafft wie es denn bei dem Thema
weitergeht
haben wir ein Gesetzentwurf auf den
Brief gebracht der den weiteren Betrieb
diese Atomkraftwerke Anfang des Jahres
ermöglicht und das ist glaube ich die
wichtige Botschaft für diesen Winter und
ansonsten ist es ja klar dass
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen und den
Parteien zu dieser Frage diskutiert
worden sind das Wichtigste aus meiner
Sicht ist dass die Entscheidung für
diesen Winter auf alle Fälle getroffen
werden und wir die Möglichkeit haben
diese Atomkraftwerke zu nutzen
keinen weiteren Frage bedarf insofern
bedanke ich mich für ihr Kommen halt
Andreas Rinke einer allerletzte bevor
alles aufbricht
offenbar ich weiß nicht an wen die Frage
jetzt geht ehrlich gesagt nehmen wir ein
Lindner und Herrn Harbeck wie lange
gelten denn die Maßnahmen die jetzt
beschlossen sind also ohne
Abschlussdatum oder sind die Maßnahmen
die sie jetzt beschlossen haben
terminiert
sie meinen das heute vorgestellte zwei
der Abwehrschirm die 200 Milliarden die
sind auf die Krise bezogen und nach den
Rechnungen die wir immer haben dann bis
Ende Winter 24 also März oder April 24
alles klar bis zu 200 Milliarden gesagt
um sehr auskömmliches Volumen eben zu
beschreiben je besser die Maßnahmen zur
Senkung der Gaspreise und der
Strompreise funktionieren Kraft Natur
der Sache weniger Volumen wird benötigt
auch auf europäischer Ebene Robert nur
du bist morgen bei energierat wird ja
über Maßnahmen nachgedacht die würden
natürlich das was wir an Finanzvolumen
national mobilisieren reduzieren oder
der Finanzminister sich auch sehr freuen
dann ist auch dieser Appell angekommen
und dankbar das Geld hat ja völlig recht
das Geld geht weg und das ist im
Gasbereich völlig klar ich wenn die
Unternehmen brechen uns hier weg wir
machen mit viel Steuergeld oder jetzt
Kreditaufnahme das muss ja auch
irgendwann zurückgezahlt werden eine
hilfsoperation und an anderen Stellen
sammelt sich das Geld so und darüber
wird zu reden sein müssen das ist ja
klar dass wir volkswirtschaftliches
Vermögen gerade ins Ausland
transferieren aus der Not heraus aber
gut sollte jedenfalls bei den Partnern
den befreundeten Ländern eben auch
gesehen werden und nicht ausgenutzt
werden
okay dann bedanke ich mich sehr schließe
diese Pressekonferenz und bedanke mich
für Ihr Kommen
en so da wollte ja fast jeder das letzte
Wort haben das war sie das war die
Pressekonferenz zur Energieversorgung in
Deutschland der Bundesregierung der
Bundeskanzler virtuell zugeschaltet
wegen seiner corona-erkrankung er ist
wohl am Ende dieser Erkrankung trotz
alledem und da war viel drin da wurde
viel Neues verkündet und auch altes vom
Tisch geschoben und zwar worum geht es
ich fasse es kurz zusammen es wurde
beschlossen ein wirtschaftlicher
Abwehrschirm von 200 Milliarden der wird
aufgenommen dafür wird ein Kredit
aufgenommen um uns jetzt in dieser Zeit
mit den gestiegenen Energiekosten um das
abzufedern was besonders auch noch
interessant war war die gasumlage die
jetzt eigentlich zum ersten zehnten
kommen sollte die ist vom Tisch sondern
das neue Instrument eine
gaspreisbremse wir können darüber gleich
noch mehr reden eure Fragen beantworten
also strompreisbremse kommt
gaspreisbremse kommt Gas Umlage ist vom
Tisch finanziert werden soll das ganze
mit diesem sogenannten Abwehrschirm 200
Milliarden ich habe es schon gesagt und
das ganze natürlich am besten so schnell
wie möglich gerade zum Schluss haben wir
noch gehört wie lange soll das Ganze
dauern für wie lange ist dieses Geld
vorgesehen bis Ende Winter 24 hieß es
wir können jetzt aber mit unserer
Expertin in Bundespolitik im Studium
Hauptstadtstudio in Berlin sprechen mit
Nicole Diekmann wir haben uns das hier
ganze das ganze gemeinsam angehört schön
dass Du mal wieder bei uns bist hallo
Nicole danke ich freue mich auch
Nicole ich würde mal sagen mit das
größte war natürlich jetzt dieser
Abwehrschirm von dem gesprochen wurde
200 Milliarden werden da aufgenommen was
natürlich als erstes einem da auch ein
bisschen in den Kopf kommt ist heißt das
eigentlich auch die Schuldenbremse das
Hauptthema im Wahlkampf auch der FDP
dass es damit vom Tisch oder wie sieht
das Ganze jetzt finanziell aus wie woher
kommt das Geld nee genau und du hast
gerade das Stichwort schon genannt
Wahlkampf in zehn Tagen sind ist glaube
ich noch wird in Niedersachsen ein
Landtag gewählt da gucken natürlich
jetzt alle drauf und alle gucken auf die
Wahl versprechen und das ist im Falle
der FDP ganz zentral die Schuldenbremse
die soll jetzt trotzdem 2023 gewahrt
bleiben gedrückt bleiben und das soll
insofern möglich sein trotz dieser 200
Milliarden bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro
dadurch dass man dafür Kredite aufnimmt
und dann ich muss mal eben nachschauen
den Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds damit füllt und aus
dem dann die entstehenden Kosten durch
den gaspreisdeckel zahlt das ist die
Konstruktion ich will es nicht Trick
nennen aber eine Konstruktion
interessant war natürlich auch in den
letzten Wochen ging es immer wieder für
uns um die gasumlage ich habe es gesagt
zum ersten zehnten sollte sie kommen und
jetzt ganz schnell ist die also wirklich
vom Tisch ist Geschichte sondern das
neue Instrument nennt sich Gas Bremse
kannst du uns dann ein bisschen genauer
erklären wieso da so lange um etwas
gerungen wurde was jetzt einfach wieder
weggewischt ist die gasumlage man muss
da immer aufpassen nicht durcheinander
zu kommen weil das eben so zwei völlig
unterschiedliche Instrumente sind die
gasumlage sollte übermorgen starten am 1
Oktober die war von Anfang an sehr
umstritten weil dadurch Gaskunden die
sowieso schon mehr zahlen müssen
zusätzlich belastet würden der Plan war
so wurde es zumindest politisch
formuliert die Gas Lieferanten die jetzt
schon unter großen riesigen Problemen
ächzen durch die ausbleibenden
Lieferungen russischen Gases zu
entlasten zu stützen jetzt hat man sich
aber vor wenn ich es noch richtig weiß
zwei Wochen dazu entschieden nee
vergangene Woche dazu entschieden zum
Beispiel uniper zu stützen einen großen
Gaslieferanten das bedeutet
Juniper kommt unter einen staatlichen
Schutzschirm wird verstaatlicht zu 99
Prozent auch andere Unternehmen und in
dem Moment war die sowieso schon
umstrittene gasumlage rechtlich total
kippelig da hat dann auch Robert Habeck
der für die Idee die aus seinem Hause
kommt auch einräumen müssen vielleicht
auch einräumen können weil er selber
nicht glücklich war mit dem Instrument
und mit der massiven Kritik an diesem
Gesetz das aus seinem Hause kam weil das
auch handwerklich von vielen stark
kritisiert wurde konnte dann also quasi
sich einreihen in diejenigen die sagten
die gasumlage muss weg
wir haben zu dem Thema gasumlage jetzt
kurz vor dieser Sendung auch mit einem
Experten mit einem Wirtschaftsexperten
gesprochen und zwar vom Kieler Institut
für
weltwirtschaftsforschung und wir hören
mal kurz in diesen Ton rein der äußert
sich nämlich zur gasumlage und der ist
da gar nicht mal so kritisch mit der
gasumlage
die gasumlage ist besser als ihr Ruf und
die gaspreisbremse verspricht nicht was
oder hält nicht was man sich von ihr
verspricht und das finde ich ganz kurz
begründen die gasumlage soll ja nichts
primär die Gasversorger retten sondern
dafür sorgen dass die höheren
Beschaffungspreise für Gas schneller
auch bei den Endkunden ankommen damit
dort dann auch die entsprechenden
spar-anreize in der Breite auch bei
denjenigen die noch Altverträge haben
wirken werden können das heißt sie gilt
ganz unabhängig davon ob Gasversorger
oder gasimporteure
verstaatlicht werden oder nicht hier ist
meines Erachtens die Debatte falsch
abgebogen wir müssen aber immer sehen
wir haben die
Inflationsrisiken angesprochen die mit
jeder fiskalischen Interventionen
verbunden sind und die gilt auch bei der
gaspreisbremse wir haben hier ein sehr
hohen Importanteil das bedeutet wie
immer sie die Gas teilweise herunter
bringen wollen es erfordert massive
Subventionen die ihrerseits natürlich
dann neue Kaufkraft in den Privatsektor
Pumpen würden und das werden dann
preiseingriffe die auch hier wieder
stärker in der Breite wirken würden und
nicht so fokussiert sein können dass sie
nur bei denen ankommen die tatsächlich
in existenzielle Not geraten damit wird
insgesamt der gesamtwirtschaftliche
Preisauftrieb abermals angefacht und das
ist destabilisierend insbesondere aber
auch problematisch für die unteren
Einkommensgruppen für die ist das
geradezu ein Bärendienst
den Ton haben wir eingeholt bei der
Pressekonferenz und jetzt sagte er das
ist ein Bärendienst gerade für also
Gruppen in der Gesellschaft die
ärmere Gruppen sind und das finde ich
jetzt auch ganz interessant also hier
jemand der sich auch kritisch dazu
äußert dass jetzt ein eine
gaspreisbremse vielleicht auch nicht das
Instrument der Wahl ist war das denn
heute Thema wurde man da jetzt auch
kritisch eigentlich mal dazu befragt
dass das wann das eben nicht so gezielt
auf einzelne Gruppen in der Gesellschaft
jetzt abzielt vielleicht auch nicht
unbedingt den gewünschten Effekt hat
diese gaspreisbremse
dieser Aspekt wurde jetzt auf der
Pressekonferenz nicht abgefragt indirekt
aber kam das durchaus zur Sprache weil
nämlich auch noch mal nachgehakt wurde
und zwar direkte Frage an den Kanzler an
Olaf Scholz ob es denn jetzt parallel
zur geplanten heute angekündigten zum
gaspreisdeckel ob es dazu auch noch mal
quasi Initiative geben würde die Leute
zu ermahnen bzw auch noch mal an sie zu
appellieren zu sparen beim Gasverbrauch
denn das haben die
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler heute morgen
auch gesagt das ist der Hebel deswegen
ist ja wir haben es ja gerade im unteren
gehört deren Empfehlung zu sagen nein
die Wucht dieser Gaspreise muss so
bitter das ist und so hart das ist an
die Privathaushalte weitergegeben werden
denn das ist das einzige Mittel das
wirklich signalisiert ihr müsst sparen
das haben die drei
eben auch gesagt Lindner Habeck und
Scholz der Gasverbrauch bei dem
Privathaushalten ist immer noch zu hoch
es wird nicht wirklich gespart und wenn
nun der gaspreisdeckel kommt ist das
Signal ihr müsst sparen ja nicht so
heftig nicht so krass und auch nicht so
bedrohlich als würden die Preise weiter
explodieren das tut uns allen ja am
meisten weh und nun also die Frage okay
es kommt jetzt der gaspreisdeckel das
bedeutet Gas wird anscheinend doch nicht
so teuer dann ist der Zwang zu sparen ja
doch nicht so hoch wo bleibt denn dann
noch mal der Appell an die Leute Energie
zu sparen bzw vielleicht auch eine
großangelegte Initiative wir erinnern
uns die Impfkampagne gab es ja auch
wobei deren Erfolg ja auch sich eher in
Maßen hielt daraufhin hat Scholz
geantwortet naja Robert Habeck
Wirtschaftsminister habe ja eben schon
kurz vor ihm dazu aufgerufen zu sparen
also da scheint jetzt nichts weiter
geplant zu sein aber ja die Kritik Klang
da eben durchaus an in der
Pressekonferenz
ich möchte gerne auch mal die Kommentare
hier aus unserer Community mit
reinbringen in unser Gespräch einmal bei
youtube hat JR abgekürzt geschrieben wie
sollen wir das noch Schultern I don't
get it jeder normale Einkauf kostet uns
fünf Personen 150 € und das dreimal in
der Woche das kommt natürlich noch an
Topf zu den gestiegenen Energiepreisen
und dann schrieb Kurt partum bei
Facebook Machbare nachhaltige Lösungen
müssen auf den Tisch was nützenpakete wo
nur einige was davon haben CO2 Steuer
weg und Mehrwertsteuer runter das ist
jetzt natürlich auch noch mal ein Thema
nachhaltige Lösung müssen auf den Tisch
war da heute irgendwie auch noch ein
Thema was jenseits von so einer
Krisenbewältigung wo es darum ging also
gibt es auch eine nachhaltige Lösung an
die gedacht wurde in jetzt diesen neuen
Paket Energieversorgung in Deutschland
da steht für nachhaltige Lösungen so hat
das jedenfalls Christian Lindner
formuliert und möchte das gerne so auch
kommunizieren Christian Lindner hat
gesagt wir kaufen uns jetzt Zeit wir
überbrücken jetzt die Zeit ins ich habe
mir das aufgeschrieben in ein wir müssen
in ein neues normal kommen und damit
sagt Lindner dadurch dass wir den
Gaspreis jetzt erstmal Deckeln dadurch
dass die Atomkraftwerke darauf kommen
wir vielleicht gleich noch jetzt ja auch
länger am Netz bleiben erstmal als
ursprünglich mal geplant und auch die
Kohle weiterläuft kaufen wir uns Zeit um
uns langfristig aufzustellen und diese
Lücke diese eklatante Lücke die ja jetzt
das russische Gas reißt das ja dafür
zuständig ist bzw diese Lücke die dafür
verantwortlich ist dass die Kosten dass
die Preise gerade so explodiert nicht
nur der Gaspreis sondern eben auch
Preise für Produktion für Lebensmittel
die müssen wir langfristig füllen und
dadurch dass jetzt ein bisschen Druck
vom Kessel genommen ist das ist ja der
Wunsch das ist ja das Signal dass dass
die Ampel heute aussenden will die
stehen ja alle vor Landtagswahlen in
zehn Tagen ja das soll der
gaspreisdeckel unter anderem sein um
eben die Zeit zu haben entspannter neue
alternative Lieferanten und auch
Energieformen zu bauen sich eine
Strategie zu überlegen die eben das
russische Gas ersetzen ersetzt genau
dieser Ersatz du hast ihn gerade schon
angesprochen die Atomkraft und auch bei
uns im Stream kommt hier die Frage von
Daniel t bei Youtube was wird gemacht um
die Notwendigkeit solcher Maßnahmen also
solcher Milliardenhilfen in Zukunft zu
vermeiden Stichwort Atomkraft
Wärmepumpen und so weiter ja Atomkraft
war eben auch ein Stichwort das war ein
interessanter Moment in dieser
Pressekonferenz denn einerseits sitzen
diese drei natürlich da um zu zeigen wir
sind handlungsfähig und wir wollen
mögliche sozialen Krisen abfedern bevor
sie überhaupt er entstehen das hat
Robert Habeck gesagt das ist nicht nur
eine Energiekrise sondern das auch zu
einer sozialen Krise werden und das
versuchen wir zu verhindern da ziehen
also sowohl
SPD Kanzler Scholz als auch grüne
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck sowie
Christian Lindner FDP an einem Strang
trotzdem nochmal Stichwort
Landtagswahlen man will gewählt werden
gerade die
fdp-kratzt in Niedersachsen an der fünf
Prozent Hürde da ist noch gar nicht klar
ob die wieder in den Landtag einzieht
und so konnte sich Christian Lindner
auch eben in dieser Pressekonferenz die
ja eigentlich Einigkeit und
Handlungsfähigkeit demonstrieren sollte
nicht verkneifen nochmal den Hinweis
darauf dass er dass die FDP seine Partei
ist ja auch fdp-vorsitzender immer noch
der Überzeugung ist dass die
Kernkraftwerke länger am Netz bleiben
sollten als es Robert Habeck gerade vor
zwei Tagen verkündet hat da ist er ja
vor die Kameras getreten und sagte okay
wir gehen nicht in den reservebebetrieb
nach dem 31.12 mit den zwei noch
verbliebenen Mailand sondern wir
tatsächlich wir lassen sie länger laufen
und zwar bis April solange wie die
aktuellen Brennstäbe noch funktionieren
also da ist ganz klar noch mal
aufgebrochen dieser Konflikt vor allem
zwischen Grünen und FDP ja das hat man
gemerkt das stimmt was natürlich auch
noch eine ganz entscheidende Frage ist
da sollen jetzt also die Preise sinken
möglichst schnell sollen sie sinken hat
man sich aber auch dazu geäußert
irgendeiner der drei Herren wie schnell
denn sowas gehen kann nee und das ist
das Interessanteste an dieser
Pressekonferenz man hat sich jetzt da
heute sehr klar geäußert über die Summe
bis zu 200 Milliarden
man will das jetzt verkaufen man will
sich verkaufen und zwar möglichst gut
Olaf Scholz sprach von einem doppelwumms
das ist total eingängig ich würde wetten
dass beherrscht morgen die Schlagzeilen
und diese politische Formulierung diese
sehr geschickte Formulierung wird es
auch in die Schlagzeilen schaffen aber
was man heute nicht präsentiert hat ist
ein detaillierter Plan wie das jetzt
ausgestaltet werden soll da sitzt eine
Kommission noch dran die hat da
anscheinend noch keine Ideen geliefert
was einigermaßen logisch ist als ich
habe es eben noch mal nachgeguckt diese
Kommission die sich jetzt um diese Gas
um diesen gaspreisdeckel kümmern soll
von der wurde das erste Mal vor rund
zwei Wochen gesprochen da traf sich der
Kanzler zur sogenannten konzertierten
Aktionen und auf der anschließenden
Pressekonferenz zauberte er dann diese
Kommission aus dem Hut die hatte also
noch nicht viel Zeit sprich noch mal
dieser Termin heute dient auch dem
Wahlkampf in dem alle drei an der Ampel
beteiligten Parteien stecken die uns
sicherlich auch der Befriedung der noch
anstehende Gespräche mit den Ländern
gestern sollte ja eigentlich MPK die MPK
stattfinden die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat sie
aber ohne Anwesenheit von Scholz Scholz
hat seine Abwesenheit begründet mit
seiner corona-erkrankung er wolle in
Präsenz Unternehmen das ist interessant
denn an den Verhandlungen zur
gaspreisbremse und an der Verkündung
heute dessen was jetzt immerhin schon
auf dem Tisch liegt konnte er ja
teilnehmen also
da wurde gestern auch klar die Länder
haben untereinander getagt dann eben
ohne Scholz die zweite Hälfte findet
dann am kommenden Dienstag statt am 4
Oktober sieht ja so aus als Kölle er
dann in präsenzteilnehmer hat ja heute
negativen Test gehabt die Länder haben
gestern viel länger miteinander getagt
als geplant da war auch viel Druck auf
dem Kessel da ist natürlich auch der
Versuch dessen was man heute vorgestellt
hat diesen Druck ein bisschen
runterzunehmen aber noch mal die Summe
steht jetzt fest alles andere konnte man
heute noch nicht verkünden
die Summe steht fest und gleichzeitig
haben wir einige Fragen in den
Kommentaren dazu wo werden denn die
Kredite zur Füllung des stabilitäts- und
wirtschaftsfonds aufgenommen wer sind
die Kreditgeber stand dazu irgendwas in
dem Papier oder wurde gesagt ich hatte
das Papier leider noch nicht vor Augen
weil ich dieser Pressekonferenz lauschen
musste ich bin leider noch nicht in der
Lage mich zwei zu teilen schön wäre es
deswegen kann ich das nicht beantworten
und in der Pressekonferenz wurde soweit
ich sie noch im Kopf habe nichts gesagt
geht mir genauso habe ich auch nicht
gehört ja genau also dazu können wir
jetzt leider noch keine Infos liefern
was ich auch noch interessant fand was
Lindner gesagt hatte er sagte der
Abwehrschirm wirkt auch als
inflationsbremse und gleichzeitig kam
die Eilmeldung während der
Pressekonferenz die Inflation steigt auf
zehn Prozent das meldete das
Statistische Bundesamt wurde er dazu
noch mal befragt auch von den anwesenden
Journalisten also das hat er einfach so
gesagt ist das so
dazu wurde er nicht noch mal befragt
aber wir haben ja eben schon den die
Auslassung des Wirtschaftsexperten des
Ökonomen gehört heute morgen in der
Bundespressekonferenz und da gab es die
Zahl
8,4 Prozent wenn ich es richtig weiß
soll im Mittel dieses Jahr also übers
ganze Jahr gesehen die Inflationsrate
betragen da sind solche Zahlen schon mit
eingerechnet es geht ja für das ganze
Jahr im übrigen nächstes Jahr
bt-inflationsrate zumindest den
Prognosen derer die da heute morgen in
der BPK saßen noch ein wenig höher
ausfallen nein dazu wurde nichts gesagt
aber genau du hast es gerade gesagt man
wartet mit Spannung auf diese
Pressekonferenz die eines der
dringendsten Themen dieser Zeit
naja nicht alle Fragen haben wir ja
gesehen beantworten soll aber zumindest
überhaupt die kommt zu oder kommt sie
nicht die Gas die gaspreisbremse während
diese Pressekonferenz läuft kommen die
nächste eimeld kommt die nächsten
Eilmeldungen zehn Prozent Inflationsrate
und darf man nicht vergessen das war ja
ein absurdes Bild da sitzt also der
Bundeskanzler quasi zwischen Robert
Habeck und Christian Lindner auf dem
Schreibtisch ist zugeschaltet per
Bildschirm dass ja die andere Krise die
parallel im Hintergrund auch noch läuft
nämlich Corona das ist jetzt gerade
durch Omikron
einigermaßen harmlos hier aber auch das
war heute morgen in der Pressekonferenz
der Wirtschaftsinstitute ein großes
Thema nämlich einmal China mit einer
sehr strengen no Collage Politik was
Lieferketten auf der ganzen Welt
komplett bremst und zwar seit über zwei
Jahren
und auf der anderen Seite sagten die
Wissenschaftler auch wenn eine neue
Variante auftaucht die auch in
Deutschland in den USA zu lockdowns
erneut führt in der Eurozone dann
sprechen wir noch mal ganz anders
also es hängt alles mit allem zusammen
da hast du recht das hängt immer alles
mit einem zusammen und viele Krisen auf
die wir derzeit immer parallel blicken
müssen das stimmt also vielen Dank für
deine Einschätzung Nicole Diekmann auch
heute wieder aus dem Hauptstadtstudio
für uns zugeschaltet danke sehr gerne
ja das war sie die Pressekonferenz zu
unserer Energieversorgung also ein
wirtschaftlicher abwärm Abwehr Schirm
ich lese es hier gerade noch mal von dem
paper nämlich vor gegen die Folgen des
russischen Angriffs Krieges so stets
geschrieben der soll uns jetzt zumindest
in diesem Punkt helfen wir sind gespannt
wir bleiben dran natürlich für euch zum
Ende vielleicht ein positives Kommentar
ein bisschen an aufbauendes Wort von
Monika bardell bei uns bei Youtube im
Stream hat sie geschrieben die bis
Deutschland ich möchte euch mal was
sagen die Menschen können viel mehr
aushalten als ihr denkt da hilft nur
eins Kopf hoch und durch wenn das hilft
das wäre schön also wir machen jetzt
erstmal Schluss bis hierhin schön dass
ihr dabei wart danke bis dahin ciao